[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
yeah the boys are back back in town
yeah no the boys are back in town that's
how it goes
i was uh austin texas oh austin be lit
was it lit oh it was lit it was great
is it are people because on the news
like i was texting when you're out there
on the news they make it seem like no
one has power anyone's freezing and like
boiling water oh no
it wasn't like that at all you were
boiling water it was cold as [ __ ] but i
mean
was it cold no i mean it was cold not
not during it's
not during the day at night it was
pretty cold yeah it was just like here
yeah it was just like it's cold out here
at night but there's no snow
a little windy but nothing [ __ ] shows
were fun though
shows were great man the shows were
great sold out
ooh two weekends in a row four weeks in
a row man we're on to something here
we're on to some people dude yeah it was
it was fun man
like uh audiences were [ __ ] great
who'd you bring with you uh my boy
ashoka
thomas i had a feature and then justin
uh justin
yes it's like a whole new album it's
from top to bottom from top to bottom
amanda's not where like i've never seen
him in the same thing never
um when you really think about it never
i've never seen justin in the same
[ __ ] outfit
no and then he brings we're only doing
two shows dog too
then he'll bring that backpack just four
separate shoes that's what i'm saying
i'm gonna be like hey doug you want one
of these like no
it's not small it's literally like from
the table the lamp
huge orange backpack yeah yeah that
would be just for your shoes full of
shoes just for his shoes it's a shoe
cloth i bet he i bet he changes every
[ __ ] outfit like
what like throughout the day yeah like
morning noon and night
how it is how were you on your diet
great man no
yeah you know austin has like like uh
they got a little hipster
area where you can find those like they
have great spots it's yeah
it wasn't it wasn't bad you weren't
tempted to cheat was i tempted yeah
come on now yeah i love food i know it's
[ __ ] tough
it really is yeah yeah yeah we are yeah
we are looking good i like that
um austin was great man shows were fire
that venue was really dope is there any
cool
i mean i might be there in april yeah
the venue was really cool great gas caps
yeah vulcan gas company so i guess it's
off sixth street
it's all right on sixth street and i
guess
they don't have comedy there a lot right
they just started to have a music venue
yeah it's a music venue i think yeah
like like
we could bring little brows if we do
that yeah dude it was literally like um
okay okay like san marcos like literally
i get down with my shows
everybody clears out boom dj party time
yeah but no it's 6th street was like
literally well 6th street's like
yeah well like it's like their sunset
yeah and it's like it was like it was
kind of like a
room in nashville and broadway was
popping
it was popping like that it was like
that oh that stresses me out oh
how about jay and then what did you want
to walk down with jay down
the [ __ ] what's the main broadway in
nashville yeah national oh it went down
there yeah yeah we went down there yeah
jay's been there 17 times let me show
you guys
for me i don't like a lot of people like
that you know some big crowds
even even like pre-pandemic no like me
that kind of has nothing to do with
pandemic i don't like crowds
like even if i go to like big concerts i
like to get a seat
yeah stresses me out yeah it's just it's
just too many [ __ ]
people and like they had their their
bars were like open and stuff
they're the guy i'd love to go down to
the bar did you see any our boys
rogan hinchcliffe tim
no i haven't seen any of them i was
doing my thing you know they do they
think i do my thing
i like how you did that i like how you
did it yeah yeah yeah i literally was
just like
i don't know because you know yeah i
mean they were sold out shows and i
and you know when i did kansas i didn't
know until like got there
or to like the like the first night but
like
austin like i knew it beforehand so it
was just like
it's overwhelming and i don't want
myself to like
you know freak myself out so i like to
have this like calm before the
storm so i just chill you know i chaos
yeah i don't want chaos i get you know
like i just kept everything
very very well you missed working out on
friday and saturday at zoo culture
guys put them guys 14 pounds
[Laughter]
no you got to get so creative in those
[ __ ] yeah you like taking
towels
yeah the dumbbells only don't even go
that high nah you gotta have
a suitcase and just lifting yeah they go
like sets of 60
yeah that's [ __ ] yeah it's a waste i
mean better than nothing
that roll machine that's where somebody
saw that you needed some cardio in that
machine i got down on that roll machine
you [ __ ] rolling machines
yeah [ __ ] okay and then what would you
do this weekend malik
well you weren't on the road or you're
here i was
on the road lancaster where's that uh
three hours up from uh north right yep
north
a rave underground underground rave show
oh hold on
yeah so much so many questions okay so
your manager or whoever booked this
[ __ ] show was like hey man you know
where lancaster you're like no he's like
yeah say less so here's
that guy it's a rave and we'd love for
you to do some
stand up i've never been to a rave i was
like yeah that's how they need
a weapon to rave never were you the only
comic only cop no they had they had
three they had three they had three
yeah yeah three comics and one came with
me do you know
what a rave is though yeah well ain't
nobody there to hear
comedy no we're all drugged up they're
licking faces
they're [ __ ] people you promised me
hand jobs it's nuts he didn't promise me
that this is that what he said he said
man
he saw because i performed at the
hollywood improv they're open again so i
did the show he was like hey bro
you know what i love you for i love your
energy do you want to
uh do comedy at a rate show i was like
what is that like like the underground
he's like yeah like edm
festivals i was like hell yeah sounds
like a nightmare but he was like
yeah he was like the only thing worse
i'm like hey man you want to
stand up at this funeral tomorrow night
the cemetery it's outside
i remember i do that [ __ ] my jokes be
killing them
yeah oh so
so so so he hit me i was like well
what's the crowd like he was like bro
it's going to be 300 plus people i was
like during kobe he's like yeah they're
all attentive
trust me you're going to do great now
it's a lot of uh he kept saying ketamine
ketamine yeah he's like gonna be a lot
of ketamine make jokes about that
i don't even know what that is don't
worry just say it they'll go crazy i
said okay cool so i get there i was like
i'm not driving because you know i got
the centra
i'm not i'm not yeah yeah yeah it's not
gonna go for three hours three hours so
i was like can i bring someone i bring
my homie
give them stage time and is this a paid
event pay get
cash cash decent pay no
yeah yeah it was only two hundred
dollars
but wait i was i know i know but i
wanted stage time that's all i'm
starving for we going on you go up all
the time around here
again but i want more okay so look all
right listen i'm man of the art
so i get there listen we get there at
four o'clock he said he promised me the
promoter
said the show gonna start at six you're
gonna go in right before they start
getting crazy before brave starts at six
it's no the comedy show starts oh the
comedy oh it goes comedy show there
they're in the rain
exactly okay okay okay get there the
promoter is already on molly
every [ __ ] show so he was like bro i'm
sorry
we're not set up we don't have the
speakers were not set up
no they were still so i get there it's
so many tents it's so
many tents i'm thinking like it's more
than the homeless people like so many
tents
and then there's like hey bro wristband
so they have like two cars right there
you can drive through
they will stop you they'll run down and
stop you like hey bro you didn't check
in i was like oh [ __ ] so he gave me an
all all past like wristband get there g
nothing everybody's high all ready and
this it's a really good oh this is your
turn
but it's only four p.m they've been
there since thursday terrain i didn't
know that
so again i'm like okay so i'm going to
put you put a video of it yeah here we
go right here this is
somewhere are you on stage right that's
no no no no no this is me like this
looks like the worst gig in there
oh yeah
you have no choice but to do crowd work
i didn't know you can't tell you can't
tell no jokes there no you're a hype man
you're a hype man exactly that's why the
guy was like oh bro you kill him did he
teach you that
they didn't teach you oh yeah so so i i
um this girl who was hula hooping
and she had like lasers she taught me uh
like how to hula hoop with your lights
yeah now was everybody white or i was
only blind
i got two other black guys and they were
darker there to participate they was
like hey bro it's good to see like one
of us i was like who kidnapped you here
i'm over here who grabbed y'all shitty
get out
two movies showing the tit chan showing
where i was in this
so the stage is outside it's like so
many so what that dudes on that's not
what you were on
no this is what i was performing now i'm
in this game
yeah you did it first of all people are
turned around
people got their backs if you zoom in
zoom in i'm sorry is this the set from
batman forever
i said that it's poison ivy batman
forever
google batman forever poison ivy that's
her
lair what a [ __ ] show i
said that or 200 dude just in gas you it
was half of in gas
oh my gosh yeah i think
yeah that's a batman batman and robin uh
with george clooney yeah you're right
when they what today's yeah that's
really no this this is when val kilmer
was batman
right yeah that was great oh no that was
uh george
clooney
[Laughter]
this girl look at the [ __ ] i know that's
a great reference so
um how many people are in there bro it's
so many people it looks like
there's so many people in the back so
it's like four tenths combined you know
what i would have done
up there like oh this is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show someone gave me a bunch of exit and
i was just had a bunch of sex
well what
uh like a long time to pay you because
as soon as i got it
because you wanted to leave after you
was done as soon as i got off the stage
they it was an orgy in that room right
now they called it the cuddle puddle
yeah because it looks like people are
sitting on pillows they're waiting to
[ __ ]
they're waiting to [ __ ] they're waiting
they're like yo bro if you're like
like if you don't do it [ __ ] up dude my
dick is wrong
we have a short window here man
i wonder what they were thinking
bringing a comic to rape and this girl
right here she was pissing me off
because she was on molly the whole time
she kept doing this yeah
i was like stop casting spells and she
put her you're in their house yeah
you're right
she pulled a test out right she pulled
the tiss out [ __ ] yeah and then they
were like bro
all right okay they started listening
yeah yeah good sex i was like well hold
on i'm not done yet
did boys have to go up too so they went
up before me i hear a lot
so how much time they ate [ __ ] they ate
[ __ ] huh how much time did you know they
hate me 15 minutes but i also don't say
headline at the rave though you know
don't say that but don't say that yeah
because there's no
well i like to think that like my set
brought everyone together because it was
a cousin
she was so desperate to get her titties
she pulled them out about just shut you
up
this we're waiting on [ __ ]
well they were getting desperate have
you ever been to a rave
[ __ ] no i i used to i used to work
security for raves and it's
a [ __ ] night yeah they go
from 6 p.m to 8
a.m all night seriously seriously it's a
it's a nightmare where they go through
to the morning yeah
everyone's malnourished drugged up
dehydrated it was a dude who was asleep
him and his dog would sleep the whole
time and it's like music blasting people
walking
dog listen and then he the dog had to
get him up he licked him he was like get
off as soon as he got up he drunk water
and he hit the vape
i was like oh this is crazy hit the vape
hit the vape i didn't know you can get
high off balloons i go in
it was a balloon tent i'm like oh cool
cool he was like yeah you want to smoke
it i said what the [ __ ]
so yo yeah wait oh like they take the
nitrogen yeah there's like these big ass
balloons that you get
what bro i did not know i was in and
they were i've never heard of them dude
little
nitrogen balloon in a dick suck what's
up
man white dudes massaging girls with
their shirts yeah
hey this uh i saw a white real [ __ ] fest
bro
that yeah i mean it's way bigger than
that chin i'm talking about way
so they oh [ __ ] yeah it was like they
were sitting like they had a balloon
tint
and everyone is sitting like that it's
like basically it just gets you high
they you lose your
those things yeah and they had like this
big ass nitrogen pumping the dude was
like
whip it it's a bad idea and i'm talking
about bro in a tent
hi oh you want to just play with your
voice
with your voice i was like yeah let's do
it
oh wow that's [ __ ] scary nightmare
yeah but wait
have you all been to a ranch and you've
been a rave yeah of course cat you've
been a rapper yeah yeah i've been to
wrestlemania yeah y'all been around
graves are like a very asian thing now i
saw a lot of myself
yeah i saw asians and whites like 2000
and i think eight or nine that
there was like a huge movement with
asians going to rapes i don't know what
it is but
like asians love it to party but it's
strictly edm music for
these things edm or house music yeah
how's music just like
trans
a remix yeah they're not just gonna play
that regular too it's like a remix
actually they played that song i
remember a guy was on lsd everybody
united and started singing
and they just start i'm like god man
they're living it was lit i was like i
need to learn that song but that is
something
so that music is going on that whole
time because you said they go from like
yeah the whole time it's not something
but how did you do
they didn't turn the music off i'm a big
fan of [ __ ] music but i don't know if
i get drugs
with drugs yeah yeah i think like you
hear something slightly different
when you're on ecstasy and then you hear
that type of music like it does
something to you like your
uh brain or your weight it just yeah
like you feel it more
that's why i've done ecstasy i have not
yeah
i think you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
what yeah
it's cheating you be living that life
yeah i mean that's i'm sure
for cats you everyone to try it oh you
guys still oh no you've never i never
i've never tried no eggs really no no no
i never tried it but they gave it i left
the brave one oh my bad we assumed my
bad dog
i bet you're recovering alcoholic and we
assume you just dabbled
in eggsy hey how dare you man no
no i bet you're in the 12 step bro
hey you know what that's where i get
disrespectful disrespect
just [ __ ] it hey you know somebody i
told my
girl i'd be home around nine no because
cause the show started at six i'll be
home around like nine
i didn't get home till like three a.m
are you serious were people all dressed
up and [ __ ]
bro everything so usually the girls
that's pretty easy
i got on yeah
and it was like guys i can't believe you
agreed to that for two hundred dollars
dude i i know
i should have called so this is okay i'm
sorry two hundred dollars
you gotta drive three howard well i i
had the guys so you said a lot a lot of
whites and asians
whites and asians like angry like asian
yeah white nation usually yeah and it
look how they're dressed
yeah but it was way more provocative
it's a real [ __ ] fest raving is really
popular over in europe too
that's where edc uh like the really big
edc yeah
[ __ ] wide she's
irish she's uncomfortable
she had too much to cover up she didn't
really want to do it
yo so so the drugs make people want to
[ __ ] the molly don't so everyone's on
molly
you want to touch things yeah so when i
get off stage that's how they greeted
you
this how they greeted me when they got
on stage so i was killing it they was
like oh my god they did the jamie foxx
rub like you oh yeah you killed it
i was like this is when this covet tent
and you over here touching my chest yeah
you [ __ ] about coving
bro it was a cuddle puddle so next thing
you know this is how it started cuddle
puddle this is how the orgy started so
did you stay and watch the
orgy yeah i would have yeah i ain't
gonna lie to you so no condoms by the
way
so they started kissing and then like
the leader of the tit started kissing
and next you know the girls like he was
a magician and
girl slowly just started like he was
making out with every one of them that
other guys came
a guy on guy hey chill there's some guys
oh yeah that's a rave no no real [ __ ] it
was some guy over here
bro and i was like hold on i'm right now
some mouth when you're on xc dog
right there i'm right there to open it
it's four big tits combined i'm right
there to open i'm watching this go down
and he was like that he had his hat on
and he was just did this
man bro it was like it was fire and it's
crazy at the same time so you just
started chugging them off yeah you
started sucking them off and then i got
dru
i got grabbed but you got into it no i i
pulled back i was like
i got you're sober yeah i'm sober yeah
because yeah if you're sober that's got
to be weird
it's weird and they had like lights and
you saw the trees you saw the plants
yeah
he was just like a guide to them yeah
that's what i'm saying like for you to
have a look at that
like yeah i mean i went to a space dogs
out there too the dogs
he was [ __ ] oh he was yeah he looked
other dogs and that labrador's a cuddle
puddle
it's real tall the dog was on molly i
think honestly bro he was licking
everything
all that for two hundred dollars
when it all you gotta pay your boys
[Music]
i can't there's no there's no gig in the
world i could stay up that late no it's
just not
the god i mean when i when i lived in
louisville like the bars closed at four
and i thought i thought i couldn't
handle it but then i was like oh i like
alcohol
i handled it alcohol let you get you oh
yeah you you it's like in vegas when you
go into that after after
partying like no what are you gonna do
at five in the morning
what else can we do how are you not
exhausted what can we do like oh
everyone's on cocaine that makes sense
yeah that was cool you were never about
that party you weren't not a part of
your nephew
you like you had fun but you're not like
never i don't like staying out late man
never have
yeah just [ __ ] they put cocaine they
put molly in the cocaine now
really yeah the girl told you she was
like yo that sounds fantastic really
that's what they just swear to god his
white girl comes out
that sounds dangerous she shouts like yo
you about to get twisted dangerously
awesome
so cocaine because okay is a downer
right no it's molly and uh what is my
arm
it's upper yeah and okay here's here's
the problem
when you come down from it though it
must be a [ __ ]
real depressed because it releases so
much dopamine that your body doesn't
have any
so then when you're coming down from it
you're just sad panda
but bro it might be worth it
she was part of that orgy she was
getting it hell yeah that's
scary because here's the in the orgy you
didn't have too much to take off you
know the girls are
basically naked yeah so none of them
were that attractive
now they had like two of them there i
was like oh i bet the two are just like
yeah yeah yeah the two no no they were
with it they were really hot girls go to
raves yeah no yeah but
it was asian it was just a summer girl
the baddest one she was working behind
like they sell water beer no food
and they know they sold no one's hungry
no one's on they sold noodles i don't
know why
yeah noodles it was such a weird rave
they had the asian girl selling noodles
two of them she was slanging she was bad
too bro i was like what are you doing
here don't they drink a lot of orange
juice on molly or something like that
that is
why you need fluids there's a lot of
water like stuff like that
electrolytes yeah liquid yeah
because you sweated
and you know it's funny they had a fake
ass doctor there with a stethoscope
and no pants that's that stupid stone
i bet you said that at the party and
even the high guy's like
[Applause]
or something come on bro
it's funnier this way it's funnier this
way yeah the stethoscope
um did he have just that in his dick out
no that would be funny so he
he was a tent doctor and you know that
guy who didn't wake up since thursday he
was
like he was like he went up to him
napping hard he pressed this on
he was like just put a blanket over him
and that was it that was the only thing
during the orgy show
he did not wake up he did not wake up
and the guy i saw the doc he was alright
cool
he didn't participate in the orgy but i
saw him get like some hit the doc
you saw get some head yeah the guy that
oh the doctor
the doctor yeah he's out she's at work
yeah you look tired dude
this [ __ ] was what saturday saturday
yeah i didn't really cost you seventy
five dollars to do that
yeah yeah yeah pay off the homies yeah
but you said what you said one dude
wasn't a comic
nah nah so so it gets there that's how
we started the show so
again everyone's jumping jumping in the
main stage so the tent is right there by
the main stage outside it's cold as hell
in the desert
by the way i wore jordans i was like oh
and we're in the sand
dirt i was like bro you had to give me
some new shoes so i i wore my homies
shoes and i was like bro
he wore his hiking boots so we we're the
tennis next to the stage
he goes the dj goes everyone's turning
up he's like you're going to see the
best comic in the world he's in the tent
right now
the show starts in five minutes i was
like
yes he did on the stage i was like who
is
yeah right next and they look they
didn't stop playing music so i had to do
comedy
next to someone who's just partying so
you hear like idiom music and just
it's just not for the space for comedy
yeah for 75 dollars
trying to get their
can you pay attention she pulls the tits
out not bad titties though what'd you do
this week cat
well well steve and i went over to your
house to watch the fight oh yeah
cheese and wine you did bring nice
cheese and wine
this is amazing barely any cheesy that
was great it was great
yeah you barely eat any cheese uh it was
stevie
joe and i we were just eating all the
cheese
you guys ate that entire thing we ate
the entire thing it was nice though
where'd you get it
um nick's girlfriend jewel literally has
a
friend who makes uh chartreutery boards
it would i found her on instagram
it's really charcuterie really good you
got it dude
it was [ __ ] nice though it was so
good it looked good
you actually stayed really strict you
had like a cheating yeah
i had i had a taco during food truck
driving
you had sort of yeah it was but i was
surprised i was like god damn
brendan really doesn't want to touch
anything down 14. bro yeah
you feel better though i feel so much
better i have no desire to cheat now
either yeah
because you're seeing the results though
i mean i guess but also i think like
you uh i just my energy is better yeah
your body gets used to healthy foods you
just feel better yeah suddenly you eat
like that one crappy thing you feel like
[ __ ] throughout
when i ate that taco i was so mad at
myself i called mike he's like dude
chill
it's okay man this food stressing out oh
i stressed him i was like
[ __ ] up bite a taco he's like don't oh
he says
yeah he's like you're fine dude yeah
because you know you're working out
tomorrow okay
you're fine but also like you you're not
gonna spend the rest of your day eating
like that
no you know what i mean but yeah i
always think about it
dude ever since we had that [ __ ]
barbecue before the show never again
i was like man this is the worst feeling
i think i've ever felt before everyone's
sleeping in the back you and justin
i'm always hungry yeah yeah the bad idea
justin's changing out his shoes his
pants my energy is great like before
this i did two hours of below the belt
because it's a big fight week so
yeah two hours this then i do here
tomorrow you get kings thing i have food
truck
probably two king of things food truck
food trucks there's power through it
damn my energy
energy yeah uh yeah i mean what food is
energy yeah
you i mean you're you only do food truck
how many times
uh once i mean twice a month but
sometimes like
like ben askren's out here training with
freddie roach so he's like hey let me
get on food truck so i'm like all right
so
we did one on friday then ben aspen's on
tuesday so that's two
yeah so okay yeah so sometimes it might
be like three weeks in a row or
something
we'll bank them i'm fine because like
with uh
i might have to have like half a taco
with ben but i figure it out
and we won't cheat in cleveland although
there's i think it's slime ends out
there
what's that what's that dude what's that
slime
bring out slimes slime slime
all right
slime is yeah i'm slimy's gonna hurt
their business
there you go slimy slime dolly dude and
they
that's what in that
they're known for that but they have
this breakfast sandwich dude
that is the best thing that's ever
touched these lips okay really
i love a good breakfast sandwich see
that's the thing like [ __ ] like that
well i just want to go there i'll just
look at that damn thing
he did he actually won a war it's like
award-winning oh it's award-winning
well so i would mean j-word of the roast
beef sandwich and he's like oh how's the
food this the owner i'm like oh it's
good
and he goes uh can i make you something
that we won awards for
since you guys in order i was like yeah
i guess man he brought it
dude me and jay split it
i'm telling you man it's the best thing
i will ever touch the breakfast sandwich
yeah i think it's uh cheese no
you salami melt fried egg is it on uh
yeah what does that mean or
you know yeah um go to
our famous sandwiches oh you want to go
to yelp
uh no
i don't i don't know if it's on the list
he he made it for us man
maybe it's like a secret thing they got
well he said you wanted
but we're not going to eat there we
probably shouldn't even go there we
probably shouldn't go there we can't we
can't walk to slime
we can't exciting i love cleveland hey
what are those little taco things
those are fish tacos it is no that's an
asian thing right yeah it's a bow
sandwich
oh it's a sandwich what's that bread uh
it's a bow
bow yeah it's like a sweet bread
no it's um chinese people have it
vietnamese people have it i would
primarily say
uh chinese see now i feel like we just
all talk about food
kind of because oh you wanna hear
something what boston
points to he'll make you he'll pull up
your shirt and point to your belly
button
he calls belly buttons boba oh
damn oh how about how about tiger right
we go in the hot tub every night
and on uh playing drake yeah
scary on friday i always do i was on the
phone dealing with some shenanigans
and i go hey make sure the hot tub's hot
dude he's a guy and he goes out there
i'm like on the phone dealing some
business [ __ ]
here's papa get out of here i'm like
hold on dude i'm on the phone he goes no
come so i'm like hey i'll call you back
hang up and he's like get out of that
coming he's like this he's holding a big
black lizard this lizard's like this big
he's holding his hands and he's crying
he's i start feeling he's like
he drowned it in the pool i'm like oh
[ __ ] dude i go maybe he's just you know
i don't want i'm like maybe just
sleeping
it's a rave and maybe he's just sleeping
and he puts him down he's crying he's
what should we do
i don't know dude push on him see if
he's alive and tiger takes his two
fingers
flips him over his whole belly's blue
and he pushes on his stomach and the
lizard's all blah
and then flips over peace is out i'm
like you saved his life
what yeah damn and i can't be a doctor
i kept dying that lizard popped up and
went i want to live and ran off
so then i tell ty here i go hey tell
your grandma he did he's like he's like
grandma
i got this lizard and then i i did this
to him and he popped and goes i want to
live
i've seen that [ __ ] happen though i have
it i was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah i've seen uh some dude did it
with a
squirrel oh yeah i've seen squirrels
yeah he did it with a squirrel like he
just like pushed on and pushed on it and
then almost
entire push on his belly was like yeah
and it came back
because i think yeah i think you might
have found it in the water or something
like that you got a doctor dooley
you think he was scared of that boa yeah
you right you were scared of that boa
i don't trust well because the [ __ ]
first of all it was calabasas steve
irwin
he was going to bring it like this where
he was like this i was like
like someone breast ain't trying to kiss
you it was terrible because i think it
easily just
oh dude and he was telling me how
aggressive it was and [ __ ] i'm like i
don't need you yeah how do you make how
do you make something like that not
aggressive
he said just play with it a lot of my
guys just play with it
you've never heard that in my life
speaking b days next week my b
day son papa
dude we got dope airbnb for my b day in
spokane right outside
uh coeur d'alene there okay right on the
lake
great club i've only been so they own uh
brick town they own spokane they own one
more
but great club it's random so well
popping oh it's popping how's it weather
is it raining a lot out there
um it should be all right look it up
even weather no uh cleveland's gonna be
cold which is [ __ ] such
a really cold yeah believe it gonna be
freezing
man uh they got hey
smoking probably has healthy stuff okay
we'll find healthy stuff wherever we go
ooh not warm it's cold but it's not 40
like 50 but at least it's just you know
56.
it's a nice but like 50 50 there in
comparison
i told you i told you i said i'm gonna
every morning i'm gonna run around the
lake and then jump in the water
oh you are i'm bringing my jump rope
okay i'm bringing my swimming pool run
with me around the lake [ __ ] a jumper
when do you ever get to run around the
lake though yeah
oh [ __ ] dude then we'll jump in the
water get all naked
in that cold there's water cameras out
there
you really want to run oh yeah i'll run
around that lake for sure it'll be fun
see would you you could you could run a
good distance i can't maybe
like the most i could do is the [ __ ]
mind okay they're like a [ __ ] mile
we'll do 10 mile there a mile back
that's two miles oh you want just a mile
total i can do a mile
all right we'll figure it out i'll walk
back it's dope though it's a it's like a
cabin house it's like cabin house would
be all snuggled up there
get stevie with his little air maxes
[Laughter]
he's auctioning hill i'll tell you what
i've been listening at the gym too and
jay said it was a good idea that takashi
six
nine bro i can't wait for something
you're on there for i was working out it
goes
hard so you actually like his music i
love it i love it
stevie hates when he put that in the
group chats like
y'all go back and forth y'all go back
and steve don't like to i told steven
i'm like i get why snitch steve's like
hell no snitches get stitches this
street color like yeah red is a rat
stevie
chilled there's a line in the sand you
don't cry
stevie got fair points you got fair
points but no way because what
he tells why he snitched and all that
stuff everybody when you hear about it
like
i would have done most people 99 of the
world do the same [ __ ]
like those guys turn their back on him
those guys kidnapped and wanted to
murder him
so then he gets picked up you know by
the feds and like yo if you don't give
us names you're going to wait for these
guys
oh you mean the guys that [ __ ] me out of
money or trying to murder me and my
family
yeah i'm going to snitch on so it was so
so it's not like they were super loyal
to him and had his back
they're the ones that arrested him and
we're gonna or i'm sorry kidnapped and
we're trying to kill him
oh and he escaped wait and that's when
he got picked up by that video of them
him getting pulled out those are those
are those are trayway guys oh those are
these are bloods yeah
oh damn it's interesting so he knew who
was [ __ ] coming after [ __ ] yeah i
knew he knew them he was like damn don't
kill me dog he's like talking to the guy
yeah
he's like he's like reggie we know each
other like he's literally like what are
you doing
he knew him reggie i i made that name up
oh
reggie sounded like a snitch yeah reggie
you know reggie sounds like a g
how many how many how many how many punk
reggies you know
two for real yeah like two i only know
two reggie
how about drake drop this weekend that's
what you should be i only heard one song
are you
serious fire he has three that's fire
he does not have you seen the video yet
yeah yeah yes he's just uh oh
like i can't figure out what car he's in
though because it's not a
not it's not a benz it's not a big it
has to be a rolls royce because
in the car that he's like spit doing
donuts in is uh
mercedes slr i think but then those
don't have back seats then in the video
he's in a back seat
and it's custom uh seats and i i don't
know what car that is
it might be no it's called what uh
what's next oh it's good
what's next he does not [ __ ] miss he
doesn't
he doesn't he has to be the best he's
the [ __ ] best us
uh now i we'll figure out what cory is
in we can't play the musical no i'm
going to put it on sometimes it'll be
tough to figure out what card i'm
telling you man
i heard the other two jay and i had an
argument the whole weekend
because baby body that that that uh
that's a
that's a that's that's slr but he's not
talking about that one that's
that's a how expensive is that mercedes
uh that that's probably the mclaren slr
so probably 300 400 grand are you
serious but see that's they don't have
back seats that has to be a
another car that's to be a maybach maybe
oh no the stars are rolls royce yeah
yeah
that interior is really dead i was like
god damn now i don't like to jump
how come you don't rock anything like
that a rolls royce yeah
they're just big man and then the thing
about rolls royce too
is um they're really expensive for
maintenance
because you you have to take the royals
royce and they're even under warranty
they're so expensive dog
no i don't know if you release one you
only get i think it's like 2 000
miles a year so you have to buy that
thing no i don't know much about
2000 uh rolls royce at all great car but
what i mean what is it
british put like this yeah i'm gonna
tell you british i'm gonna tell you what
the player told me
your girl would be in the rolls-royce
before you get on your [ __ ]
oh for real all right well but if
if i was going to get something like
that like a four-door sedan i'd go with
a bentley
i'm more of a bentley guy than
rolls-royce yeah baby bellies are dope i
can't
i like the bentley four-door yeah the
four-door did you see two chains
bentley truck uh-uh those bentley trucks
are dope
let me see rolls royce or bentley don't
really hold their value
so i used to have the bentley uh super
sport that's us that red one i had that
and
silver yeah you had that yeah damn damn
i had that like
four years ago five years ago and
bitly's british yes
pure british it's a great car great
[ __ ] car
see the floor the silver one next to
that chin
where's that oh right next to it see the
silver one right next to the picture
you're on
no no the picture you're on doug the
four door
what's up that's what you had no that's
what i if i would get a sedan that's
what i do
how much is that price starts at 220.
that's in 2021.
you can get an older 20 like a year old
one and save half your money yeah like
like what's the grill why you wanna you
wanna you get like
i do not you do like you two i'm 14. i'm
okay with my g 70 or 80.
okay 70 or 80. yeah like a nice one for
90.
um but yeah that's yeah i don't know if
i get a roll like that
no they're they're great [ __ ] cars
there's i think even
like i honestly think even if i had like
just [ __ ] a massive amount of money
you will
i still probably watch i no i won't
i'll probably still rock the jeep
seriously yes
i don't know there's just something
about those cars that like i don't try
to do a custom jeep though like that one
i see
a picture of like ortega's yeah dude
that's a hundred thousand dollar jeep
that is yeah ortega's once you do all
that stuff you're only in a hundred
grand
because you try to get something like
those those jeep rubicons are expensive
dude
when you do like the lift the engine the
transmission
all the intentions oh that one you sent
me no yeah that that one that one off
the lot was a hundred grand
that one was yeah i'm talking about
ortega's
it's the same thing really mm-hmm
look at that guy
i'm more of a bentley guy than bro
that's so rose royce you kind of feel
like a [ __ ] driving it
you do i mean i'm sorry am i am i in g
unit why am i in this car
all the athletes have them look at that
[ __ ] beast
what am i looking for yeah it's a
hundred grand dog what about when he was
doing donuts in it
or he was just he put like a
supercharger in it
yeah all that i mean you look at you're
over 100k for all that uh i don't know
what a supercharger is i don't know cars
so don't don't beat me up
then you don't need that but you could
get it you know like what does this come
with supercharger just like
it's a supercharger on the engine so
more horsepower more boost
yeah yeah that's
that's i mean that's handsome looking
guy i don't yeah i don't need like that
there's a dime piece
i don't need like uh there it is
i'm sure they hooked them up but hear
how loud that is super charger
can it burn out though yeah dude
i don't even know how to do that how do
you do that
yeah oh yeah i would like that yeah for
sure
but yeah i don't know like bitly's and
all that stuff and
no not into it i don't like small cars
either i don't like smart
small cars like i'm a big small car kind
of guy like yeah
you don't like like m3s and [ __ ] what's
the
m3
bmw two-door two-door i don't think i've
seen that before
smaller cars smaller car you don't like
it smaller than your porsche yeah
well they say it's the same there's
something smaller than your porsche that
porsche is pretty small
um that's no that's a sedan that's a
four-door
that looks good m4 the m4 is a coupe
though uh
m3 or m4 m4 because jay and i were
looking at that m4s are cool
that's what jj was like you had an acura
uh no
sick honda civic see that right there
the coupe that's where
yeah those are dope yeah that blue they
come in two are done i want i want one
with red seats though i love red
interior like cats
yeah i got that red interior cat how's
that only fans popping
oh yeah popping i forgot all about
popping i'm learning a lot
really how so let's take a little break
cause i'm here to tell you there's
nobody on the planet like you so why
would you sleep on a basic ass mattress
that's built for everybody else
you shouldn't that's why you need helix
sleep all you gotta do is take a short
little quiz it takes two minutes
and then they match your thick body type
and sleep preferences with the perfect
mattress just for your thick ass
with your side sleeper hot sleeper plush
firm with helix there's no more
confusion
all right there's no average mattresses
we got you covered i have in my crib
all i can't get with my friends my
family my mother-in-law father-in-law
they're all trying to sleep on my helix
mattresses it's annoying
but also shows you how god damn good the
beds are all right i've had them for
years
they love them all right just go to
helixleep.com
take the two minute sleep quiz and they
will match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
10 year warranty get to try out for 100
nights risk free they even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will
helix is offering you guys 200 off all
matches orders and free pillows
for the listeners at fighter and the
kids go to helixleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep.com fighter
for up to 200
off spring breaks coming up kids so
guess what it's time to get hairless
with manscape don't be all hairy at your
party
even if even if you can't leave because
of cover you're doing the spring break
at your crib you don't want to be harry
man
that's where manscape comes in they have
an exclusive 20
off discount when you go to manscape.com
fighter
alright manscape is dedicated to help
you level up your full body grooming
game
they have the perfect package 3.0 kit
comes with the lawnmower 3.0 waterproof
cordless body trimmer
ton of other liquid formulations to
round out your grooming routine
they got you covered man they got nose
trimmer hair trimmers
ear trimmers we got you covered man the
crop cleanser body wash all right
the uh just get the perfect package for
frick's sakes all right
freaking do it man the crop reviver ball
toner all right
stop design and make them nuts smell
good for limited time
subscribers get two free gifts the shed
travel bag and the patented high
performance reducing chafing manscape
boxers
get 20 off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
fighter do yourself a favor and always
use the right tools for the job
again get 20 off in free shipping by
going to manscape.com that's 20 off
and shipping by going to manscape.com
say
aloha to your new beautiful nuts
manscape.com
i got that ready too cat how's that only
fans popping oh yeah
popping i forgot all about it i'm
learning a lot
really how so um i found that there are
certain things that you can do
to just like sell more pay-per-views and
stuff like that
request yeah it's just like if you have
any extra
content you can send it out in a mass
message and then you pay to see it
so like there's stuff that you'll post
and you get because you
subscribed and then there's stuff that
you could buy extra if they have extra
content to sell
there's actually a really cool girl who
reached out to me she watches cats she
is on only fans too she's killing it
it's a community yeah and then she's
like helping me she's hot
very hot tattoo artist tattoo artist
what else
out here what else um i don't know she's
from out here
but yeah she reached out to me and uh
she was giving me tips so so tattoos how
tall is she
um she's giving you tips yeah does it
affect your work now that twitter has
the
super fan thing because that's it no i
saw that and i was uh curious about it
but it seems like not too many people
want to actually use twitter for that
yeah no like i think it's like they came
a little too late to the game with it
plus i feel like it's been just popping
twitter's gonna start
poaching people from only fans to go
over twitter and pay them
i don't want to see my porn that's kind
of what some people started doing with
only fans though right and only fans
yeah only fans reach out to a bunch of
people a bunch of celebrities like uh
cardi b darno uh rawlings was one of
them they wanted to legitimize the
platform by getting people who weren't
doing porn
to come over to only fiance just do
whatever they want like fitness stuff
things like just like oh got it that you
won't yeah
anybody could go literally you don't
have to be a second dick on that yeah
now pay-per-view that's personal request
uh you could you could do customer
requests on people like um
i was watching a documentary on hulu on
only fans
there uh you can basically either open
it up so you could do custom content
some people
will say like oh i want a video of your
fee and you
saying my name my name is disney's child
and so then you record your fee
you say his name and then you send it
out and the only way they can act
get access to that video is if they buy
it for how much you listed it for
so you can do that or uh you can just
sell whatever extra stuff you have it
doesn't have to necessarily be custom
content
because some people will go out of their
way to go through messages and then
do whatever it is that's specific to
that person so they go one by one
damn but some people will just have it
you know like do you know like the
like who's the top earner yeah who's the
top earner no they don't tell you who
the
top earners are but they do tell you how
like where you rank within the top
earners
that one girl remembering that she
[ __ ] it all up but i know she was one
bella thorne yeah bellathorne i think
to this day is like top number one point
zero one
damn what about erica minas they'd be on
there i don't know i don't know oh i
know that i'm sure she's doing really
well but i don't know how well she's
doing
i just know bella thorne because bella
thorne was like the big name that kind
of came out a lot of people are making
yeah good money on that
a lot of people are making really but
social media you can [ __ ] you can get
some bread off
but i'd be mad if i subscribe no offense
i'll be mad if i subscribe to like
like only fan and it's just like her
instagram page now i got to do the
pay-per-view too like this is she
getting burned from you
okay here's the thing a lot of uh people
will let you know what it is
what do you mean you have the option to
give you a heads up
yeah a lot of people give you the heads
up like this is what i'm gonna post
yeah so you know what you're subscribing
to yeah she's like that's not honey dick
and i'm like who
am i yeah
yeah there are a lot of girls who do
that but i'm like
i guess i'll buy this are you is
uh get like their initial big push is
like they kind of allude to them doing
nudes and then you buy the extra stuff
and realize that they're not doing
anything but you're not going to at that
point like
yeah but you don't keep fans that way
because you choose whether you want to
resubscribe or not
it's not like you're taking your money i
wonder if there's like a
review page like a yelp page oh yeah no
it's called reddit
yeah like yo i went to cats and it's
dope or i went to
these girls and she sucked and blah blah
blah oh really so people
people be talking i'm sure i'm sure even
on your instagram people like yo
dope pick your feet or whatever i'm only
fancy yeah do you get those comments
yeah well i don't really go on instagram
that much anymore anyways
i'm mostly not only fan so like anytime
i see something it's always through
people will buy only fans or at least
mine because they're more likely to
interact with me because i don't even
really look at my instagram anymore
i'm just not only fans so even if you
want to message me like hey i like the
show today like i'll respond back
the only thing that's only on only fans
you guys get back on it she said because
they're they're nicer
yeah they're nicer so i'm more likely to
like interact with them so like some
people
will hear us talk about air fryers and
then they'll send like chicken air fryer
recipes
what what's what's like the most
scandalous pick you've posted on there
i will do like uh anything that like
those old school like 2000 impor models
will
what does that mean so like if i'm in
like a wet t-shirt and i'm not wearing a
bra i'll just post that but you can't
see
it
pay-per-view cat now my dick popped
captain his grandchild
nervous was that a standard
jeep grand cherokee now one thing about
these import models were like the it
girl in my high school like that's what
every like little asian girl wanted to
be
growing up and then the moment i started
making money on only fans i was like
live out my high school dreams now yeah
like if you want to borrow my cars and
[ __ ] cat will you do that
a long time ago because it was my idea
i'm a businessman i would have gotten 10
a long time right
damn that's my gift to cat so what about
me i want to do that
no we don't want you on there you can
borrow my
chappelle up in my car like
i'm like bro your [ __ ] is on my
[ __ ]
chair man
he's all in the backseat just what's
that like
what's the meme when that guy just holds
the big dick yeah yeah
he passed away he did he died yeah i'm
like
big tiger's child seats next to him he's
old
i'm like hey my
kid says you can't take pictures anymore
in my [ __ ] car
i shaved today brendan that's all i love
damn but you're growing on it
but you could borrow my car scout if you
want oh that's cool most of the stuff
that i do is like from home
i take pho photos so they probably
appreciate that then
yeah i think a lot of people like to be
like cat house
yeah they're like oh like i get to see
like parts of like where she lives or
like what she does outside of work i
think that's what a lot of people
who subscribe to me personally like
where it's like oh what's she up to
you show the new crib on there uh i
didn't show the new crib but i take
photos in the new crib so you can kind
of
they know yeah they know what's up will
stevie ever make a cameo on there
no he doesn't really no it's one of
those things where uh i think the only
thing i would ever have stevie do
is because there are a lot of people who
want tickling videos
so it's like a video like of my feet and
someone tickling my feet
they want to hear me laugh while like
there's a camera recording my feet
getting tickled
that's the only time i feel like i would
have him on it what happened to regular
sex
what the [ __ ] hey that's all right
look at him i just spit my own ideas
or people just want to watch tv [ __ ] me
on only fans which i'm not doing
yeah i'd pay for that i'm not gonna lie
to you i'm not gonna lie to you
i'm thinking about it i pay hard cold
cash for that how much how much you
think
like if she the amount of money i would
make if i sold
that a sex tape of stevie and i would be
insane
because the amount of like people
offering in my dms i'm like
oh if i ever wanted to make a very
pretty if you hit rough times
or you want like a down payment on a
house if i wanted a down payment on a
house that's the video i would tell i'm
not gonna lie i helped
i helped for it now this is a down
payment on the house and he was like you
know i'm selling this video
to support you by now if it's a grand
yeah wait oh [ __ ] which is crazy a lot
of people because there's a cap on how
much you can tip someone or send someone
what's the key
absolutely it's a hundred so what a lot
of girls
anything over a hundred you send to
their cash app or their venmo
and then with your username so only fans
doesn't take a cut and then they
you send them the video hell yeah that's
what you you just
okay that's why like you can charge
essentially whatever you want but now
it's outside only fans it's
in your case and they don't take a cut
of it yeah it sounds better do your own
platform yeah you're really deep in this
i'm telling you that's why she's not
even on instagram anymore she's on only
fans
when we count on only fans and she has
her only cat on only fans
only taco oh yeah that's right they're
on food truck tomorrow
oh my sister was on my only fans
recently oh
like she was like in the middle in the
back yeah which she was
in the mirror in the back she wasn't
like actually doing anything people
freaking out
yeah they're like oh when's your sister
getting only yeah listen she was just
your sister could make decent money she
could i think
my sister's where i'm at now like
for me three months ago where it's like
oh like i could but i don't know how
much money i would make i don't think
anyone really cares i can't
we don't know to dip your foot in the
wall and then my sister comes home from
like a long day of working like an
actual grown-up job making like eight
dollars an hour yeah she's like
only fan i think she's holding out a
little bit more but what's her name
catholic cafe now we're seeing her feet
now i'm without squid here's the thing
my sister's feet aren't great
they're not like yours because she used
to play soccer so like the cleat feet
just like i'm just she's a paddy though
and some guys like those [ __ ] up feet
yeah some people do like [ __ ] up a lot
of guys like like weird
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] the feet that's why you
draw the line
have you seen her sister i don't give a
[ __ ]
[Applause]
your cat's sister has new cat's sister
has a tail dude i'm like
yeah cool okay okay she's a centaur i
don't give a [ __ ]
that is bad man she could be a pegasus i
don't give a damn
that's very progressive oh my god well
okay
right well i'm just saying you know i
would love your sister i'll subscribe
yeah we all would we promote on taylor
we'd promote it on here too for you yeah
i think she's just waiting for that one
day where she's like [ __ ] this should
be the day
she's gonna listen to the show and she's
[ __ ]
yeah we just put the energy out there
for him yeah i'm trying to work on this
[ __ ]
job let's get you some money true i'll
let her know
i'll let you guys know if she ever has
an only fancy yeah start chipping in
what's up girl i know damn well you just
say i'll give [ __ ] she have hoofs
yeah she would brenden i promise i
wouldn't i've seen her sister in
pictures
never in person but never likewise all
right well
she's like she's like a little asian
unicorn i don't know i've never seen her
i don't know if people [ __ ] with
[ __ ] up feet i didn't know that either
bryce uh
i i'm personally i'll say i don't give a
[ __ ]
would you care if cardi b's feet were
[ __ ] up yes
really i'm a big i'm a big nom have you
ever dated an athlete
like a soccer player or a cheerleader
yeah yeah
like a guy with a big day cheerleaders
[ __ ] up
if i caught you no no
[ __ ] up feet they might no no some
mice
i'm sure there's some yeah it's all
about women
oh god i was like my feet are fine no we
talking about women like if they have
like working feet you know what i'm
saying yeah you know that working she's
like washing her feet
on
i'll pay her bills wait what what huh
what do you got china
did you do anything oh yeah i just went
to palm springs
is great oh it's cool yeah pretty much
it's three of our friends birthdays the
same
in march march is like a big birthday
month for us too so we just had a bunch
of
bunch of friends over and watch the
fight were they actual fight fans were
they talking like
during the whole they're talking oh
there's nothing worse but we also did
some other stuff too
like what like what just stuff like what
drug let me be drunk is that that right
so the thing is we have like a very very
close-knit group of friends right
you know each other for 20-plus years
sure so every now and then we have a
get-together like this we kind of just
want to
you know feel the love feel the love
what do you mean
you had a crunch barbecue
we all might have taken something they
helped you feel the love and we all just
got together what did you guys do you
guys like you can guess it you were high
up during the fight you guys are like
he said we could guess it you can guess
no i'm not trying to watch the fights
and
like play maybe there's some dude in the
background too
yeah so you was raving you had a cuddle
puppy yeah kind of like cuddle puddles
all homies all friends oh wow so all the
homies is out here cuddling we're all
we're all super
it all right but it was cool imagine you
being with like all your
your close friends i'm not taking
everything brings that [ __ ] up in the
airbnb on the road i'm not taking myself
next week
if you guys want to do it uh let me know
because we know where the
quality stuff is no i don't know
interesting yeah i'm good all right
all right let's be down hard unless
you're awesome [ __ ] no hard guys
no hard pass steve you i'm trying to
think of our crew stevie would be down i
feel like
justin i could talk justin to it jay
might be into it that's three that's a
party
and then you [ __ ] can watch on the
sidelines so yeah i was yeah
you're not watching this cuddle puddle
i've already seen the cuddle puddle like
i watched it and i know chin one
see you do some [ __ ] some cuddling it's
just it's just a really nice loving
mouth on my right chest it's not enough
am i right chin no a mouth it was six
uh three couples no no just three people
it was their birthdays but all of our
friends came out
so you all had a 20 person cuddle puddle
we weren't like we were just like
you know love you love you love you hug
you alone
if you guys ever have a chance to do it
barbie you're popping that night
molly turns you gotta try it you gotta
try weekend for chin yeah that chin gets
a few days off
molly [ __ ] during the fights i didn't
say what it was
ching is wild man i saw those [ __ ]
she was bringing up you didn't invite
cat or nobody
that you guys are new you're not
inviting me i know you didn't invite me
plus i know you guys already having the
watch party at your place so i didn't go
you didn't know what i was doing i
thought you guys were all going there
love you
love about you and then we'll just try
to talk to each other all right man
that's the best i feel like they did
more but you won't say [ __ ] of course
bro
listen you know what bro took her
tits out
that's a sexual environment though this
is like just a loving family you guys
said ufc
fights yeah have you seen joe rogan
almost
you should do this by the way what just
like a bunch of you
know close friends no we need girls dude
yeah my girlfriend was there but i mean
just
with your girls just have like a you
know because everyone's close in your
family right
pretty close you'd get weird if i was
high it's not that way though it's just
really
chin it's nice what's the [ __ ] i don't
know it's funny yeah
you guys aren't open-minded yeah i gotta
be open-minded
i'm with chin and cat well the three of
us would do it no you
you you keep saying that but when you
see like dudes kissing dudes and girls
i don't give a [ __ ] but it's a rise
right i don't care if dude's kissing
i don't give a [ __ ] he's not like trying
to get rid of you
okay all right you feel good for them
you know that's that's lovely that's
right
i literally wouldn't know this is
strictly i wouldn't be like oh good for
hillary all right
dude y'all was strictly based off the
emotion of love
love friendship friendship friendship
love yeah we all
we knew each other for how long over 20
years did that give you guys did you get
that guitar yeah right
get that guitar there's too much music
in the background you're not going to
hear the guitar
[Music]
when the beat drops and you guys were
there friday saturday
friday i was there friday and saturday
they stayed until like sunday wow
what a weekend for chad i know right
it's nice it's beautiful i finally did
something i know where the raves are
finally did something well i'm just
saying like usually it's a junior oh
yeah it's a guy
murdering fish like you actually did
yeah
yeah you you went outside the box that's
what you did yeah there was a pool there
too
palm oh is a warm area so yeah palm
springs is great my boy lives there man
it went up though it's like a million
dollars a house out it's been like that
yeah seriously
yeah palm springs always expensive oh
damn
all right first one
okay i didn't watch it i haven't gotten
around to watching it yet but it made a
lot of headlines
oprah actually did a sit-down interview
with meghan markle and prince harry
talking about why they left the royal
family
how life has been since they've left her
and her new child
and she's currently pregnant as well oh
wow um what ended up happening was there
were a few things that oprah
really like got shocked by one was that
megan said there was a conversation
between people in the family
about oh like you're have with prince
harry like oh you're having a kid with a
biracial woman
how dark do you think your kids are
gonna be like what do you think that's
gonna look like it's not a good look for
the palace and the family the
institution
as she referred to it and then she then
said that like
because of her child being born they're
the one child without a title or any
security to take care of it weird
and then oprah asked if it had anything
to do with the child being part black
and she's like
well i can't really say but it i did
find that it was weird while i was
pregnant
they were telling me your child will
never have security the same way the
other royal family members do
and your child won't have a title uh but
there's
but there's also i mean you know me it
sounds good oh you mean the royal family
that's been around for [ __ ] ages is
racist no [ __ ]
but also uh with the security stuff
they're also not at
they're not at the headquarters where
like they live with the queen in the
castle i think
they moved to [ __ ] canada so they're
like yeah we can't do security oh she
was talking about uh before they left
the royal family oh
this was like
uh they were told that their kids would
never have security the same way the
other royal family members had security
and they wouldn't have a title either
so i think it was a combination of those
things while she was pregnant she kind
of
like the hormones were bad people
paparazzi were tell
telling stories about how she made uh
the duchess cry
and this and that she said that the
duchess actually was the one crying the
duchess
uh made her cry on her wedding day she
said she was suicidal she was she said
she was suicidal
because think about this because you
think about this on social media you
might get a few hate comments or
whatever
you deal with it she had the entire
media of the uk which is vicious coming
at her every day
so she had to deal with that and like
you can escape social media that's
whatever
but you can't escape the yeah
the fourth yeah yeah so she said that
she was very suicidal and she would
force herself to go
accompany prince harry to different
events because she didn't trust herself
being by herself like just alone at the
house and so
uh after that interview came out a bunch
of people are coming out to social media
and trying to defend her support her
saying that the real family is [ __ ] up
good luck coming at the royal family
though right that's why
they're wrong what you end up missing i
think it's more so people now because
the whole like free brittany thing
and then this happening people are much
more protective of celebrities
good good that's what takes the change
good she also said that she
was actually speaking to somebody within
the
uh institution she keeps calling it the
institution i guess it's not like the
actual royal family members but like
someone who works for them she said she
wanted to go
get help for her uh like a mental mental
health right yeah for her mental health
she basically went to hr and they're
like we can't help you
to let her because it looked bad for the
they said the bad luck but she also
wasn't a member of the family or
something like
there was something like something about
it which is weird
basically she was doing a lot of
shadiness and like yeah just
fully accepting dude think about the
queen's son
who was with jeffrey epstein we know for
a fact he was on the island
and he [ __ ] with that girl and that
[ __ ] idiot did an interview basically
outing himself
and then they they hide that like that's
that it's
dark [ __ ] dude yeah damn they also think
they don't know for a fact this
conspiracy stuff sam tribute no more
and eddie bravo they also think the
queen elizabeth is the richest person on
earth
really yeah but she doesn't like
broadcast or finance because real estate
money right
every they own so much [ __ ] they think
she's and they're jewels the royal
jewels like
crazy she's a lord
yeah she's the queen of england dude
it's nuts you gotta have to watch the
interview
i want to watch the interview i kind of
do but i also just got the
the you know the cliff notes yeah got
all set
all right i think i still say they were
mean to her
black girl in the royal family yeah
there's gonna be some paint your way
yeah
they've been around for hundreds of
years they're gonna be something they're
white white like pure white
yeah like in red white yeah i mean you
know it's tough
she was grating suits though i love
megan mm-hmm she was grating suits
i've never i i love people yeah yeah you
didn't watch me i didn't know i didn't
know she was an actress for the longest
time
yeah she left the show because she
started dating uh prince harry that's
why she left the show got it
yeah okay so charles barkley came out
recently in an interview and said that
he
was trying to lose as much weight as he
could in a short amount of time because
his daughter is getting married to a
jewish man and a part of the ceremony
they're gonna have to lift him up in a
chair
and he told his uh soon-to-be son-in-law
like i need everyone on deck to help
carry me i'm gonna lose as much weight
as possible
but um i'm just gonna i hope you guys
can lift me if you can't that's fine
and now he's trying to lose a bunch of
weight because he doesn't think a bunch
of jewish people are going to be able to
he said he's 250 he's definitely more
than 250 yeah
he's six he's everybody's more than 266.
yeah
he's definitely there's always hey
listen there's always something that'll
hit you
that make you realize damn i gotta get
on track yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah and this finally hit him how old is
charles barkley
[ __ ] uh i think that's been there 50.
and two to his
i mean better late than never but 58 wow
58 [ __ ] wow he's old oh
you understand michael jordan is 58.
there's no way he's 250.
he's so big yes yes he's right there on
his wikipedia 250s
he said he didn't know about that part
of the ceremony for a while and so he
didn't
diet or anything and then they he found
out like a little over a week before the
actual ceremony was gonna happen
that they were gonna have to lift him up
on chair and he got super self-conscious
so he has to lose weight in a week
yeah so he's trying to lose a bunch of
weight in a week that's tough good luck
yeah
takes forever yeah yeah losing weight
like getting shape's a slow boil
slow boys it's a slow so you don't see
results within a week
right no no okay so
uh chris cuomo is getting a lot of
backlash because
uh he was on tv with uh what's that
guy's name
len don lemon don lemon there you go
uh he was basically singing the good
times uh
uh anthem and the other man
lemon said oh how do you know what this
is like it's a black show
and he's like oh you know i'm black on
the inside just making a harmless joke
don
lemon say anything uh i think he was
just laughing like they were just like
friends
joking about it and then when it hit
social media people
started going after cuomo like crazy
saying that he's racist
he's wrong natural appropriations
yeah the cuomo allegations are weird
that one lady was like yeah she was like
oh he held
he hugged me too long am i yeah so he
should lose his job
he basically said he said i'm not
stepping down every time that like you
re
reiterating a girl really came at him
because yeah he's more alex this one was
like yeah
we were at a hotel and he he helped he
held the hug way too long
oh and that was like a report on cnn i
was watching big time
i was like that was a headline that was
a headline yeah the latest one there was
like yo
another sexuality i'm gonna go he's
[ __ ] then you look in there like
hell didn't hug too long uh he was like
he's also 60 something hold up wait
oh i was trying to read that tweet
you're good oh go ahead
which one it's just stupid [ __ ]
the offensive one yeah what
it's [ __ ] offensive uh black isn't
something you just can say what you feel
are
inside without having to deal with the
racism that comes out with being
he was talking but he was saying a joke
yeah it was a joke it was a joke
it was very very much we're all locked
down right now
everybody's all super yeah it's i mean
listen this is cultural appropriation
come on come on you took it that
seriously you took
it that seriously people need something
to be mad at man like
that's serious i was at a rave i was
like i'm a little white on the inside
it's so dumb bro that's really i guess
yeah that's dumb what else you got
so over the weekend in arizona there was
a
yup shout out arizona there was a fight
that broke out
uh inside of bath and body works because
there was
two customers in line one of them uh
wasn't wearing a mask and she was
standing very closely to the
woman right in front of her and she she
was being a little rambunctious about
not wanting to be socially distanced
because she's like what's the big deal
blah blah blah
and somebody starts recording right when
the fight broke out
and this fight went viral all right
let's see it let's see it okay
the workers try to step in to stop but
they ended up getting in the fight
oh wait which she's fighting with the
world no they're trying to help then
she's trying to
contain her so she's someone from
the woman in the striped dress was the
rambunctious one yelling
the girl in the black top i believe was
the other
customer the workers tried to get in
between them wait why is she fighting
them because
just they tried to separate them and
then the employees got so frustrated
with what was happening that they
started to fight the customers
in shape i was about to say
bro what video are you watching i know
i look down
dude these are like ladies fighting yeah
yeah
some grown-ass women like yes
well that looks like so this is so
arizona yeah who's that
[Music]
uh bbw employee
tried to de-escalate but the white lady
wouldn't leave so that's what
it picked up white lady pushed many
people for it and also
she was loud and uncooperative oh the
whole time
right right so casually that's so
expensive i thought she's like gonna be
serious
bbw you could have left that out
show you what she was doing oh wait no
she probably was being serious
oh oh this is a better uh angle well
she's saying bbw bath body words
i was thinking i i didn't i know i
thought it was i'll say oh
my bad oh okay i i just got that okay
my bad oh man that kind of sucks i
wanted it to be bbw
that's why i was like it could have been
either way yeah
all right well so what happens nothing
uh nothing they just
both got kicked out of the bathroom body
works
bbw that was in scottsdale yes
scottsdale arizona oh i could tell
oh you can tell [ __ ] yeah why what gives
it away it's just that whole
whole vibe oh there's like a different
vibe from scottsdale to
versus mesa yeah oh there's a big
difference
oh okay if it was mesa what would they
look like uh
they look like uh who i'm thinking about
uh they look like they do from uh
what's that breaking bad what's that
guy's name oh uh brian cranston
no the other guy the younger oh jesse
pinkett yeah they look like that like
just kind of
oh they look like him yeah like kind of
you know somebody that's a little
trouble
even though even the women makes a
little trashy yeah yeah yeah a lot of a
lot of methamphetamine
they look a little skinnier they look a
little skinnier you know
the hands would be all dirty you know
black like they'd be like they're a
mechanic but they're not
going to be in bath and body works they
wouldn't be in bath and body works crash
yeah they'd be at the circle okay what
else you got jane uh
here some outdoor parks stadiums will be
eligible to open
at limited capacity yeah i don't get a
twist we're still in the red zone but by
april 1st we should be open where i
think dodgers have around 11 000 people
okay all right i'm cool with that and
the restaurants they say indoor
uh should be open next week really
indoor
oh [ __ ] really yeah that's something so
that's cool theme parks finally yeah
they're open at disneyland but td's
gonna be [ __ ] but disneyland's only
uh is are they doing a limited
competition
everything's gonna be limited capacity
for now yeah there's probably gonna be
like a reservation situation i wonder
how they're gonna like um
like six flags how they're gonna do on
the rise like what no opening maybe like
every other row
like depending on what your group size
is it's actually kind of good though in
the beginning i think
yeah yeah because if you have more room
there's too many [ __ ] people anyway
yeah
it's way too mine's gonna be longer i
don't give a [ __ ] okay gonna have to sit
next to people and you know well the
mines would have been long regardless
though if it was that normal
yeah it's not like disneyland is super
super crowded even with fast
fastballs disneyland like two years ago
it's a beast yeah
you still wait
all right cdc now recommends or is
saying that if you're fully vaccinated
you don't necessarily need to wear a
mask
with other fully vaccinated people like
you could be in the same place with
someone that
is fully fast vaccinated and not have to
wear a mask or be socially distant
so we're progress very much yeah my papa
got vaccinated
both of them are like both of them this
is done so you get to go outside
he has to wait a couple weeks i think
though after your second vaccination
i know so many people to get it no no so
many people too yeah
are you gonna get both shots am i yeah i
mean
if it's here then i'll do it yeah but
yeah i mean i don't know you're not
gonna go out your way that's basically
what you say
yeah probably not if if they go hey to
travel you have to have it like
that i'm
all right all right chappelle check this
out what happened washington football
team is replacing cheerleaders with
co-ed dance teams
so no more just women it's going to be
co-ed and focused on dance
like if they if they kind of label those
[ __ ] as cheerleaders one more
time
oh god oh god i'm gonna come down there
they're not they're dancers but that
ellie ran's been doing this for a hot
second
yeah ellie ren's been doing this yeah
but i mean there's
most teams honestly there's some schools
that already have like co-ed
like dance teams like there's dudes out
there but they're not i mean
when i tried at louisville uh we had a
couple dudes on our
on the the dance team yep do you like
that better
it's just a co-work dance team i mean i
like it better
than the [ __ ] go team like that
shit's lame
i like it when the boys drop it
we get loose
it's an old traditional style of
cheerleading which is like i mean
cool yeah you know what i mean we get a
megaphone and you know yo
yell [ __ ] no one's into that no one no
no i don't think anyone just had a game
any time i've had the megaphone
in my [ __ ] no one gave a [ __ ] have
you been to like someone shouting with
me
have you been to like an hbcu game
lately man them things up the bands are
nothing yo
they dancing it's like no chill they're
dancing howard
yeah howard grambling southern
university jackson
uh the drum line right now yes i'm
saying that been
that's been going on with those dance
teams it's just now getting popular yeah
yeah they lit though drum lines talk
yeah
you talking about that remember drum
line that dude they doing part two
i hope no they did it they already did
it
he's not in it then i don't want to see
it i thought they were doing part two
now
no they doing it you can google it they
already have a part two it's called the
drumline a new beat uh-huh
and it's the girl who's playing the
female hey what did rotten tomatoes give
it
uh i don't think it was it was on vg vh1
it's obvious oh
is it like this the scorpion king where
the second one isn't even with the rock
cause like yeah
exactly like that okay but uh wild
enough she's back uh we should be happy
what does he say 37 yeah he's awful yeah
nick cannon's back on radio too now he's
he's back he slowly coming back wild or
not he's coming back in april
wow what do you got jen um let's go with
give us one more this one seth rogen
said that kanye west
at one point had him in a limo and and
wrapped his entire
album to him and it took two hours
doug after 30 minutes like dude
[Laughter]
this is really cool and i appreciate it
but yeah
i understand you're kanye yeah that
would drive me [ __ ] crazy
who just started yeah i would have i
would have told her
like hey i'm done put like this dude
after 20 i'm like damn yeah
dude that was cool after two songs yeah
give me two songs and i'm good you know
what's been
so awkward in the back that just the
limo just be like okay
yeah dude after an hour you're like how
long is this gonna [ __ ] he said it
took me two hours just put it i'd have
been like
hours of my life though did he say he
had a good time
he enjoyed it it was him and his wife i
think he said that they were in shock in
the beginning just like what the hell
i started rapping yeah no beat all
acapella so you know they did a movie um
the kim jong-il movie remember that seth
rogen and james franco the interview
and i guess around that time they also
did a music video where kim kardashian
and kanye west on that motorcycle that
really
cheated yes they did a what do you call
a spoof of it and then kanye saw it and
then this happened
afterwards so kanye's kind of like i
don't know maybe that's his revenge or
something
oh what else is weird
yeah that's a weird yeah yeah yeah let
me wrap my whole [ __ ] album
oh you always make a spoof you're a fan
though it's kind of fire
your own private little concert well i'm
with my wife
that's like that's like someone sitting
in the back of them and telling like
communities
yeah i'm gonna do my hour set for you be
tough with your girlfriend
[Laughter]
your girl looking at you he doesn't stop
either no
what if it's adam sandler or something
like that though like you're you know
yeah
but he's going to run an hour set hours
are you with your girl in the back seat
of a limo yeah my favorite comedian i
i mean i couldn't listen to my favorite
comedian in the back of a limit dave
chabelle was like hey
mind if i run my hour by you what's your
girl
sure oh i'd feel so much pressure like
yeah you would just do it
i don't know after 45 minutes be like
y'all still would do it oh yeah i do oh
but your girl gonna look at you
it looks like no she didn't shut her
[ __ ] mouth
you have to they are one of the goats
yeah you got in an hour you need a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well this cruise in cleveland this week
we are saturday sold out so we added
tickets to thursday and friday so get
your tickets this thursday friday
uh cleveland ohio at hilarity's march
11th through the 13th
then spokane washington next week uh sat
friday and saturday sold out
and thursday so we added a late show
thursday and early show
saturday so those takers available now
spokane washington march 18th through
the 20th my birthday holla
and then back on the road three weekends
in a row march 25th through the 27th
we're in miami florida miami improv uh
so get your tickets at fatkz.com
cleveland europe see you this thursday
friday saturday uh think boy gear we
have
six jackets left to sell out thick
uh boy nation jackets the letterman
jacket the maroon hoodies and the black
hoodies
thickboy.com follow your thick needs
that's fire yep that's it kids
good show we're out good [ __ ] are you
how are you feeling now yeah hey malik b
aka rolly boy i'm from the foe but i
love me a threesome
that was hard that was hard that was
hard huh
no because that's a little baby
he said but or too bad i'm taking i'm
not liam neeson that's what he said
that was the next bar man right now
right now yeah
yeah ones these are ones i wore to the
rave bro so they they was in the sand a
little bit
yeah yeah yeah you was you know what i
mean
is what it is nice thank god bring it
one night
you already know what it is fella lacy i
love his titans so are these vans
little shoe surgeon bandana custom
donkeys
the best shoe we've had no camera
check him out instagram at shoe surgeon
[Music]
cool go check out the at shoe surgeon
shoe school where he teaches people how
to make these sneakers from scratch
and they just launched their second
series of online classes with monthly
enrollment is now open
two weeks from today then it closes so
if you want to learn how to be a real
sneaker head make your own [ __ ] like
this these custom kicks
that celebrities get if you like shoe
surgeon
check them out at shoe surgeon on
instagram
i mess with a lot of custom kicks
they're a nightmare because people make
their own versions
[Applause]
is
surgery